welcome to the Silla forum a monthly
Oxford style debate that features topics
of special interest to libertarians
thanks to the Smith Family Foundation
for making this series possible we'll
live at the subculture Theatre in New
York City but I'd also like to welcome
our online audience for our first solo
forum livestream I'm Jean Epstein and
economic journalist and the director and
moderator of the solo form here's how
tonight's debate will work the audience
initially votes for against or undecided
on the resolution and you can do that
now but going to sell ho ho dot-com s
oho vo t e sell o vote.com will be the
closing the closing the voting in a few
moments and at the end of the debate
you'll have a chance to vote again and
whoever moves the needle in his or her
favor is it is declare the winner
tonight solution is as follows the US
government should unilaterally abolish
all tariffs and duties on imports and
all subsidies to exports thereby making
all reciprocal trade agreements with
other countries unnecessary one more
time the US government should
unilaterally abolish all tariffs and
duties on imports and all subsidies to
exports thereby making all reciprocal
trade agreements with other countries
unnecessary so get your votes in now
also for the audience at home submit
your question in the comments section
and we'll pick a couple to be read aloud
during the Q&A session now on to the
event defending tonight's resolution we
have George Mason University economics
professor Donald Boudreau done please
come to the stage
opposing the resolution we have
Americans for limited government
president Rick Manning Rick please come
to the stage we are now closing the
voting Don Boudreau you have 12 minutes
to defend the resolution the US
government should unilaterally abolish
all tariffs and duties on imports and
all subsidies to exports thereby making
all reciprocal trade agreements with
other countries unnecessary
take it away Don thanks gene I'm happy
to be here the economic benefit of free
trade even unilaterally adopted free
trade is that it ensures access to the
maximum possible quantity of goods and
services and the maximum possible
variety of goods and services in
contrast restraints on trade
artificially reduce people's access to
goods and services restraints on trade
create artificial scarcity I ask how can
we be made richer by our government
obstructing our access to goods and
services regardless of what other
governments do goods and services that
we judge by our voluntary actions by our
spending our own money to be worthwhile
would you be enriched if government
annually destroys say five percent of
your household goods let's say you own
$50,000 worth of household and personal
goods and furniture like a sofa and a
desk of appliances like a washer and a
dryer coffee maker you have an
automobile in your garage
you have clothing in your closet you
have pharmaceuticals in your medicine
chest would you be enriched
if each year the government hired thugs
to destroy twenty five hundred dollars
worth of these possessions they break
into your house and destroy them of
course not while a few producers might
benefit say the furniture maker who
sells you a sofa after the thugs
destroyed your older one clearly you and
your family are made poorer
this policy that is explicitly designed
to increase the amount of scarcity that
you must endure a policy of protective
tariffs differs in no economically
relevant ways from a policy of routinely
deploying thugs to break into people's
house to destroy household possessions
the only difference is superficial a
policy of protective tariffs
artificially reduces the amount of goods
that you and your family enjoy by
reducing the amount that you initially
acquire while a policy of deploying
destructive thugs reduces the amount of
goods that you and your family enjoy by
reducing the amounts only after you
bring those goods home
either way you're poorer many people
reject this comparison of destructive
thuggery with protective tariffs surely
government orchestrated destruction
differs fundamentally from trade
barriers they say but they're wrong even
protectionist cannot avoid admitting
that trade barriers and thuggery have
the same initial effect fewer goods and
services available for peaceful people
to consume our replies to protectionist
said Coleman productions the key word
here is initial we protectionist
advocate the artificial creation of
greater scarcity today as a means of
increasing abundance tomorrow the
artificial scarcity that we create with
trade barriers creates more and better
paying jobs at home thus increasing
abundance tomorrow if you fall for this
protectionist canard understand that a
policy of destructive thuggery can be
justified on exactly the same grounds
the government can point to the jobs
that exist only because it hired thugs
to bust your sofa to pieces and to slash
the tires on your car so I urge you to
ask a protectionist what's the
difference if a job in say the domestic
furniture industry is created because a
government agent prevents you from
buying a chair made in China compared to
a job in the domestic furniture industry
being created because the government
agent destroys the chair that's already
in your home
in either case a job is created in the
furniture industry and you must spend
more money to buy a new chair aha shouts
the protectionist with a gotcha grin
unlike the destruction of household
goods trade barriers forced you to buy
more domestically made goods if all the
US government did was to destroy
existing goods Americans would replace
many of these with imported goods and
does not support American jobs
trade barriers ensure that domestic jobs
are created wrong protectionist failed
to see a fundamental feature of all
trade namely sell or sell only because
they want something in return
foreigners sell to Americans only
because they wish to buy from Americans
or to invest in America and foreigners
are the same as you if you ask yourself
while you work the answer ultimately is
to earn income in order to buy goods and
services or to the extent that you save
to buy goods and services tomorrow
what do foreigners who supply Americans
with imports do with the dollars that
they earn the same as you spend or
invest them in the United States and
dollars spent and invested in the United
States support jobs in the American
economy no less than if they are spent
and invested by mr. Chen Li from China
or mr. Chuck Li from Virginia when mr.
Li from China sells furniture to
Americans here installers he spends some
of these dollars buying American exports
he buys say american-made
pharmaceuticals the dollars he does not
spend he invests in America he se opens
a restaurant here in Manhattan in both
cases jobs are supported in America and
so by preventing the Chinese mr. Li from
selling furniture to Americans not only
does our government directly make us
Americans as consumers poorer by
obliging us to pay higher prices for
furniture our government also destroys
jobs in industries that produce US
exports and in industries supported by
foreign investment you see it isn't true
that imports destroy jobs I challenge
you to look at the data you'll find that
as imports into the US have risen over
the years both absolutely and as a
percentage of GDP there has been
absolutely no effect on the number of
jobs none international trade neither
destroys nor creates jobs on net instead
trade shifts jobs from sectors where
workers produce less efficiently to
sectors where they produce more
efficiently a trade barrier that
protects say Jones job in the steel mill
destroys Smith's job in the tire factory
or the pharmaceutical lab no one denies
that trade destroys particular existing
jobs but trade also creates other
particular jobs those jobs are destroyed
by protectionism and so if someone
insists on focusing only on the
particular jobs destroyed by
trade in order to assert that trade
destroys jobs I can assert with equal
validity that protectionism destroys
particularly jobs and say protectionism
destroys jobs a larger point is that all
economic change destroys some particular
jobs and creates others international
trade isn't unique in this front if you
choose to eat more meals at home you
destroy jobs and local restaurants if
you go to the on the Atkins diet you
destroy jobs and breweries and bakeries
and you create jobs and on cattle
ranches and on pig farms if you quit
smoking and become more health-conscious
you destroy jobs in the tobacco industry
and create jobs at gyms international
trade is just one of the many different
avenues on which travel the forces of
healthy economic competition and of
positive economic change and in the
large countries such as the United
States trade remains a relatively minor
source of job destruction and creation
the upper estimate get this the upper
estimate of the number of jobs in
America that have been destroyed by US
trade with China since that country
entered the WTO in 2001 is four million
that's the top estimate do you know how
many jobs are destroyed on average each
month in the United States and I'm
talking about quits I'm talking about
jobs destroyed because the consumer
demand for those jobs have fallen the
answer is 17 is gonna be 1.7 million
each month on average 1.7 million jobs
in the u.s. are destroyed because
consumer demand for the outputs of those
jobs have fallen but also other jobs are
created which is why each month we see
generally except in recessions a net
increase in jobs 1.7 million on average
destroyed and roughly 1.8 1.9 million
jobs created so my point here is that in
any average 71 day period in the US and
period of just seven weeks there is a
destroyed by your economic change has
nothing to do with the not much to do
with economic even with international
trade as many jobs are destroyed in that
seven week period as it has been
destroyed by the the the allegedly
horrible trade we've introduced with
we've had with China over the past 16
years
what about allegedly unfair trade
practices by foreign governments should
we retaliate when Beijing say subsidizes
producers who compete with American
producers no I agree that such trade
practices are unfair but they're not
unfair to Americans they're unfair to
people subsidizing the excuse me they're
unfair to the people of the subsidizing
countries a foreign government subsidy
might well enable foreign firms to sell
more to American consumers but two
important facts go unnoticed by those
who call for US government retaliation
first the subsidy isn't free that
subsidy draws resources away from other
sectors of that foreign economy into the
subsidized sector so unless you believe
that government agents are somehow
miraculous at directing the economy
foreign government subsidies make that
economy less effective it draws
resources away from where the market
would direct and put them in and puts
those resources into less efficient uses
the second thing that's missed by those
who call for retaliation is that those
subsidies make us Americans to the
extent that we buy the subsidized
exports from those countries
it makes us richer we get these goods
that artificially low prices we're no
more harmed by getting gifts from
foreigners then you're harmed if you get
a gift from your neighbor look at the
data and look at history the freer is
trade the higher is both the country's
per-capita income and its rate of
economic growth we can hypothesize you
can spin stories about what if this what
if that but history knows of no country
that has been held hostage to a country
that practices managed trade in all
cases from Hong Kong a perfectly free
trading nation and Britain in the late
19th century a perfectly free trading
nation - not quite perfectly free
trading but still largely free trading
nations such as the u.s. becoming more
free trade over the post-world War two
period as nations become freer in
trading they become wealthier the
average standard of living Rises I do
not understand those people who like mr.
Manning who his organization Americans
for limited government takes a lot of
positions that I heartily support I
understand why I say Bernie Sanders
supports
section ism he doesn't like the market
so it's natural for him not to like
trace now for him to trust government
bureaucrats to run foreign economies
well and to run our domestic economy
well I don't understand people who claim
to support the market who support
protectionism that's supporting
intervention by government bureaucrats
protectionism is government intervention
and it's government intervention always
against fellow citizens it artificially
raises the price American consumers pay
for household goods it artificially
raises the prices at American producers
pay for raw materials and inputs it
artificially reduces capital
accumulation and entrepreneurship in
America and are artificially fuels
special interest politics and
rent-seeking which is what always
happens when you have government
involved in directing economic matters
it trusts politicians in bureaucrats
with all the power to superintend the
economic affairs of all Americans
protectionism makes us less free and it
makes us less prosperous regardless of
the practice of other countries thank
you
[Applause]
Thank You Don Rick Manning you have 12
minutes to take the negative on the
resolution take it away Rick let me try
to get my actual notes in the right
order here because I discovered it's
just my surprise that when I was sitting
over there that my actual presentation
was somewhat just was it was supposed to
be so that makes things interesting but
let's see if I can find them here we go
okay so gene I really appreciate you
having me here you know as an on account
the Economist when I received the
invitation to participate here I've kind
of felt like a Christian being invited
into the Colosseum to meet the Lions for
dinner but however since this debate is
largely a political one and not an
economic question I'm confident that the
audience will find that I have some
smooth stones at my disposal to take
down this Goliath after listening to the
affirmative I want to remind you the
audience of what this debates about
because he didn't talk about the actual
affirmative the affirmative is the US
government should unilaterally abolish
all tariffs and duties on imports and
all subsidies to exports thereby making
all reciprocal trade agreements with
other countries unnecessary this
resolution rises or falls on three words
unilaterally should and unnecessary
because ultimately the affirmative
demands that the US should in the real
world take unilateral actions which in
practical application will cause
reciprocal trade agreements to become
unnecessary so as we begin we'll examine
these three areas even if he doesn't
want to let's start with the terms
unilateral and reciprocal unilateral
action is the opposite of seeking
reciprocal trade agreements as a
precondition to lowering tariffs and
lifting subsidies but reciprocity is not
merely a negotiating stance as we shall
see it has been a basic building block
for sustainable free trade and other
agreements in modern history in order to
understand that the need for reciprocity
prosity one need only look at professor
boudreaux's owned
globalization a $61 requirement for his
econ 309 students at George Mason
University professor Boudreaux writes
unequivocally on page 123 quote by far
the most important modern institution
for Modi promoting freer international
trade is the general agreements on
tariffs and trade GATT end quote why is
that well as Professor Boudreaux
explains in his book GATT was based on
reciprocity and he account lines all of
its advantages quote under GAAP
countries mutually agree to lower their
tariffs and to grant most favored
trading status to you remember the GATT
agreement from each government
perspective the immediate gain the gain
is most politically beneficial is that
each government can assure its citizens
that exchange for lowering tariffs at
home that government has extracted
promises from foreign governments to
lower their tariffs because each
government's tariff reductions are bound
together in a single agreement no
government has to worry that it has well
lower tariffs without other governments
lowering their tariffs simultaneously
and accordance with the terms of the
agreement end quote his words as the
book continues professor Boudreau must
agree that lower tariffs have only
encouraged more global trade arguing the
result has been freer trade it was GATT
which propelled us tariff rates on
imports to fall from an average of 30%
to at the end of World War two to about
5% today and drove down tariff rates all
around the world between developed
nations GATT facilitated the tariff
reductions at the affirmative world so
desires proving that the tariff
reduction could not be done unilaterally
but only through reciprocal trade
agreements which the affirmative
declines professor Boudreaux ends the
argument succinctly on at page 124
writing quote no others such as straight
sustained decrease in tariff rates is
found in US history end quote
he also adds most informed observers
credit GATT for the success in short it
is none other than Professor Boudreaux
who persuasively makes the case in his
book that the mutual reciprocal trade
Graham is a GATT are the only reason for
the sustained reduction of tariff rates
worldwide we see today if the goal is
free trade if the goal is to continue
reducing tariffs
another non-tariff trade barriers around
the world in a sustainable manner you
must vote against the affirmative
because you need reciprocal trade
agreements to get there in contrast I
expect something will be made today
about Singapore's long-held unilateral
near zero percent tariff for a number of
reasons this island nations experience
negates all three of the affirmative
burdens unilateral being more desirable
in reciprocal the real world should test
and the reciprocal agreements being
unnecessary tests it's instructive that
his Singapore inter GATT with her near
zero tariff rate in 1973 their Finance
Minister Hong Suisun argued vociferously
for developed countries like the u.s. to
lower their tariffs noting that
Singapore had already unilaterally
lowered theirs Han also urged special
and deferential treatment for developing
economies were by developed countries
lower their terrorists first in order to
help the lesser developed economies grow
but since Singapore's tariffs were
already low Han demanded no such non
reciprocal protection for Singapore from
Singapore's perspective then it was
seeking receipt reciprocal trade tariff
reductions from the developed economies
and they're entering GATT was a
reciprocal trade agreement to disprove
the affirmative one only needs find a
single reciprocal trade agreement I've
already mentioned being necessary in a
post unilateral tariff reduction
environment here with Singapore we have
several to look at 30 years later
Singapore succeeded in getting Russert
reciprocal trade deals permanently
eliminating all tariffs with the United
States and Australia and many other
reciprocal trade deals with other
countries
coupled with the sustained dramatic
decline in tariffs globally under
reciprocity achieved under and GATT it
would be foolish to move away from the
only proven model for success which is
reciprocity Singapore also negates the
real world should problem for the
affirmative by providing a real-world
example of a nation that created the
framework to succeed in global trade
through key domestic policies which
besides reciprocity and trade from
developing economies are the true reason
it competes well with its trade partners
in 1965 Singapore became the end
it became independent from Malaysia and
put temporary import quotas in place for
a small number of products for the next
four years during that period there
single-party government single-party
government and in labor strikes by
eliminating labor unions aggressively
built industrial infrastructure educated
people for industrial technical jobs
reform fiscal and monetary policy and
only then eliminate the important port
quotas into qatar lee the affirmative
makes no such preparation for the US
economy for what would be a dangerous
unilateral action should the affirmed
and succeed currently the US has a high
the highest corporate tax rate in the
developed world an onerous regulatory
regime designed to export environmental
risk and restrict the flow of capital a
free market system that does not engage
and top-down industrial policy and
education system that emphasizes liberal
arts rather than technical education a
robust two-party system of government
that slows the legislative action to a
call crawl which is a good thing and a
constitution this tariffs embedded into
it
not to mention politically potent labor
unions unlike Singapore the affirmative
since it doesn't mention it would have
politicians make the unilateral tariff
cut to zero without at least
significantly lowering corporate income
taxes was rolling back large portions of
the administrative regulatory state all
guaranteeing a massive political
backlash and failing the should test at
this point I'd like to augment this
should slash reality argument to the
export subsidies statement in the
affirmative for the past 70 or so years
conservatives and libertarians have
argued and I was one of them for ending
agricultural subsidies buta laterally
they've failed seventy years of failure
the reason is if you look at a map it is
a red sea of ink in terms of the
electric electoral map from the
Appalachians to the Tehachapi Mountains
and California it is Republican country
is farm country and Republicans you're
free traders aren't going to vote to end
subsidies because if they do they will
have the same political fate that tim
Huelskamp had where he voted and
recalled show subsidies in kansas and
god vote became former representative
Tim kills camp shortly thereafter again
the affirmative has no real-world
solutions because the fact is the
politics are for gradual
decrease of tariffs gradual decrease of
subsidies reciprocal arrangements that
make sense and and cause a gradualism
that gets us to where we want to go
that's the critical piece on this should
finally the affirmative concludes their
statement thereby making all reciprocal
trade agreements with other countries
unnecessary as you recall the negative
has already shown that Singapore is a
nation that unilaterally ended tariffs
proves a negative by virtue of their
subsequent aggressive pursuit of
reciprocal free trade agreements the
fact is the reciprocal free-trade
agreements are not just or even
primarily about tariffs or subsidies
they're about the conditions of trade
including but not limited to labor
conditions intellectual and physical
property rights protections dispute
resolution regulate auditory
environments customs rules social goods
and human trafficking among many others
because Professor Boudreau makes no
accommodation for non economic reasons
to maintain reciprocal trade deals the
affirmative position can only be that by
lowering tariffs to zero trade deals
that protect against the predatory
taking of intellectual property become
unnecessary
similarly anti-human trafficking
provisions and trade deals become
unnecessary in the affirmatives world
the affirmative is wrong they are dead
wrong in fact one of the most
significant trade deals in history
involved human trafficking after Great
Britain eliminated the slave trade in
1807 it then pushed France and Spain to
join them in the anti slave trade
treaties of 1814 and 17 these major
seafarers jointly agreed to end the
slave trade to use their respective
nations of force agreement here's the
truth it was that agreement that it that
Abraham Lincoln signed in 1862 that put
the nail in the coffin the Confederacy
because their hopes of having an
agreement with it with Great Britain to
keep them economically solvent went down
the toilet because it was a moral
imperative not an economic imperative is
a Great Britain's advantage to have to
have an economic agreement with the
south it was in their advantage to have
a an agreement with the south because of
increasing their Imperial Empire they
chose the moral commitment and that's
why people why you cannot just judge
trade agreements based upon an economic
model because that's not
the real world its unassailable that
modern bilateral and multilateral
priciple trade rooms have many elements
beyond tariffs making them necessary
even in a unilateral zero tariffs and
subsidies environment could at the end
of the day the US will want to export
goods and commodities do that you'll
need the like and all likelihood need a
trade deal with the countries you are
supporting - overall the affirmative
fails all three of its tests one
professor Boudreaux asserts in his book
that was a reciprocity that's been the
vital component to missus tanning and
expanding free trade not unilateral
action to the real world should test
Boudreaux imposed the real-world should
test Boudreaux improves upon himself
fails miserably just ask my friend form
of representative tim Huelskamp and
three trade agreements with other
countries will remain necessary
regardless of tariff rates and subsidies
because tariffs and subsidies are but a
small part of modern-day reciprocal
trade agreements as such you must vote
for the affirmative or for the negative
got it backwards
[Applause]
donggu Joe you have five minutes of
rebuttal
take it away Don first let me clear the
room of the red herrings the
intellectual property issues slave
issues any non trade or moral or ethical
issues can be dealt with independently
of tariffs designed to restrict people's
access to foreign goods and services the
vast majority of trade restraints are
justified and in fact are imposed not to
protect intellectual property they are
imposed to protect domestic producers in
the home economy I have never denied as
my dad in my book I don't deny it
of course it's true that in the
post-world War two ERA the reciprocal
trading agreements have indeed lower
tariffs but that's because we live in a
world in which governments are intent on
protecting the home producers in their
jurisdictions and it so happens that
because people think exports are a
wonderful thing and they're the purpose
of trade when countries get to trade
with one another one country does agree
to reduce its export scheming introduce
its import tariffs as an alleged a
concession to another country to allow
that second country to sell goods in
that in that first country the argument
is not that what I understand the
argument here is it's not what is what
has been the most effective way of
reducing tariffs over the past 80 years
of course the history makes that clear
it has been the reciprocal trading
arrangements that we've had under Gatton
and later WTO my proposition is that
even better would be for each country
including the United States to
unilaterally abolished our tariffs we do
not need to wait for other countries to
abolish their tariffs before we abolish
our tariffs in a at least among
economists a very famous point
attributed to the British economist Joan
Robinson and I think it's exactly true
Joan Robinson said the the notion that
we
lower our tariffs only on the condition
that a foreign government lowers its
terrors first is akin to saying we
should clear our which is sucks cream
you should stop throwing boulders into
our harbors only if the other country
stops throwing boulders into its harbors
GATT and the WTO have made world trade
freer they it has been a success story
and even better policy however would be
to reduce for each country reduce trade
barriers completely eliminate them
completely and the United States does
not have to wait for China for Japan or
any other country to do so in the same
way that New York doesn't have any trade
Barratt barriers against any others any
states we we don't need other countries
to stop hurting themselves in order for
us to stop hurting ourselves Rick is
right that there are a lot of I'm sure
we would agree on on most of them a lot
of awful bad policies in the United
States taxes are too high
regulatory burdens are too heavy I agree
with that but I don't see how that
problem is solved by then saying okay
we're gonna put this other tax on
instead we're gonna tax our our imports
as well that's just a tax it's just
another government intervention if these
other government interventions make our
economy so problematic and make us so
unproductive or less productive than we
otherwise would be what is solved by
putting on another tariff another tax
that's what a tariff is it's just a tax
I don't see any reason why the
interventions that we all in this room
most of us in this room regard is
detrimental to an economy suddenly
become beneficial to an economy when
they're done when they're put on imports
one quick final thing before we go I
don't know if you know but about 66
percent about two-thirds of imports into
the United States today are raw
materials and inputs into American
production and so if you 2/10 that we
have tariffs on those imports that's two
thirds of our imports not consumer goods
raw materials and imports
and and and in in in intermediate inputs
to the extent that we tariff and
restrict those imports we raise the cost
further of American producers that
doesn't make us more productive that
makes us less productive thank you
Rick Manning our five minutes for
rebuttal from you thank you again I'm
going to read what the affirmative is
supposed to be defending the US
government should unilaterally abolish
all tariffs and duties on imports and
all subsidies to exports thereby making
all reciprocal trade agreements with
other countries unnecessary it's really
difficult to have a discussion when
we're talking about two different things
but this is the affirmative this is what
we're here to talk about you know I'm
gonna give you an example and it's gonna
drive professor Boudreaux nuts but it's
a it's a good example there's been for
many many many many years there's been
an attempt and I supported it to get rid
of sugar subsidies you know what we had
still have sugar subsidies because when
you run at full board straight ahead
into a buzzsaw you always end up getting
chopped to bits
okay that's the strategy let's run into
the buzzsaw again this year and see if
we can get I could chop to bits this
year happens every year
so we I had a crazy kind of concept and
it was why don't we support something
called zero for zero and what it does is
it relies on reciprocity Congress under
zero for zero would automatically Minh
ate sugar subsidies contingent upon the
president going to the WTO and
eliminating and getting India Brazil and
others to bring their subsidies down to
sufficiently so the president would
certify it at which point the sugar
subsidies would go away now it seems
like a pretty obvious way things since
we know we all agreed that reciprocity
has worked yet
it's a somehow using reciprocity as a
means to get rid of Agriculture
subsidies doesn't seem to fit the
bill of let's let's put our face into a
ceiling fan and see if we how much we
like it every single year you know
politically we have to deal with the
real world and that's why I brought up
the red state stuff they the real world
is you don't get to just say gee we're
gonna eliminate so you know laterally do
stuff because when you do as Don wrote
in his book again you have a what
happens is the pain is narrow is very
narrowly focused in his extreme and the
benefits are spread throughout the whole
economy so people all I get minimal
benefit that they don't actually bring
any that they don't see as be related to
that and but the people who got and who
got their piece taken away what is not
done through a through a systemic way
like respond to a reciprocal agreement
those people are very mad and that's why
the net result of Don's proposal of his
affirmative would be the Republican
Party in Congress would get wiped out
now some of you might think that's good
idea and I'm not far from you but the
alternative is not a libertarian the
alternative is Bernie Sanders and worse
and so if you went with if you go with
the affirmative you have to agree that
there's nope that the political risk is
worth the downstream payoff here's the
challenge with the downstream payoff we
don't know what it is we don't know what
it is it's a what we do know is that
what we have been doing has limited and
lowered tariffs since 1945 from 30
percent to 5 percent we're on a pathway
to eliminating tariffs altogether unless
we go crazy and do something
unilaterally and cause there to be a
backlight political backlash that ends
for a generation the opportunity to end
it being a tariff free environment
that's why I said this is an economic
argument it's a political argument
that's why I took this debate I'm
appalled it's a political guy ok I'm
about winning and I'm tired of losing
for 70 years anybody with a you know if
you sit in it if you've got a job and
you're getting paid anyway and you've
got a tenured professor you can talk
about this stuff all you want my jobs to
win
and this is how we're gonna win so I
would encourage you to negate the
affirmative and let's do let's find the
use the tools that have worked so get
ourselves back on track and create an
environment where we have American
interest protected yes but we're doing
it in a way that opens opens markets so
they're even freer and more robust thank
you now in this part of the debate each
side gets to ask the other two questions
we will alternate Don first a question
from you that you might want to put to
Rick I puts in a term of a question I
wasn't aware that this was a political
debate I thought I was making an
economic argument I understand that
tariffs have been lowered again by
reciprocity but what why can't we have
an intellectual discussion that explores
not just how to form today's winning
political coalition which I agree is
important that's not what I'm here for
I'm here to make a case for the proper
and death trade policy it's happened in
the past we've had Britain that had for
your trade I want to make a case for
free trade I don't I'm not here to form
a political coalition that's going to an
I'm here to educate people about trade
I'm here to persuade people on trade why
is that an illegitimate thing to do why
should I be concerned about the politics
of the matter John because the
affirmative who says should in it and
not ought to the word should means it
should it's a policy that ought to be
that the government needs to take that
the affirmative is saying needs to
happen now it is an action word it is
not a wishful word we're not sitting
here in Galt's Gulch okay we're not
sitting in Galt's Gulch we have to just
come to that realization we're sitting
in America we're sitting we're
surrounded by people who want us dead
and and that's a real-world
consideration and when I deal with
real-world considerations
in on Capitol Hill when I deal with
real-world considerations I don't take
night lightly when somebody throws
something out academically that would be
politically and economically disastrous
and that's why we should talk about the
political end because should is in the
affirmative and that's in that you have
to defend the affirmative Don yeah you
have a question for done Rick yeah Don
do you still believe that reciprocal
trade deals will be unnecessary given
the important non-tariff elements to
these deals yeah
please defend it please please defend at
all all unilateral trade needs is a
government says we will no longer
interfere with our citizens decisions on
their own how they spend their income we
will no longer discriminate against
goods and services made abroad compared
to goods and services made at home
period end of story
that's all we need to do Don you ever do
have another question for Rick yep
huh you you I think you slipped in your
last comment there you seem to suggest
that even let's let's assume for the
moment I know it's academic and I'm I I
am that academic right yeah I know I
don't take that as being a good thing to
not anyone I didn't say otherwise let's
we'll have to watch it on the character
assassination guys yeah go ahead let's
say that politically we could do it
Britain did in the mid 19th century and
in fact go to unilateral free trade you
do you believe that would be
economically disastrous you seem to just
that you just said so yeah because I
think versa prosody is the right way to
do it no you you ask the question no I
get to answer it the reciprocity is as
you pointed out has been the key to
success not unilateral in fact you know
what the last you lateral law that was
passed in Congress but to deal with
trade smoot-hawley so you got
smoot-hawley is your last unilateral
thing that was done and after that we
got the reciprocal reciprocal trade act
which then set the
for unwinding smoot-hawley and 70 years
of lowering trade tariffs so if you want
to engage in unilateral action the
unintended consequences can be enormous
li take note bad and that's why I think
that we want to go with with a with a
reciprocal barge Richter you have a do
you have your second and last question
for Don sure given that you're so fond
of the consumer price being low no
matter what the how them Goods got their
juice do you support slave produced
goods being sold in United States come
on no no well then you support
restrictions no I don't know what by the
way what's slave goods are being sold in
United States
um palm oil from Malaysia there's a book
that's about this thick that the
Department of Labor effort does that the
Department labor puts out every single
year slave trade by the way when you eat
a candy bar the cocoa that comes from
the candy bar from the Ivory Coast is
produced by slave labor so just just be
aware that yes there is slave labor and
when you eat your candy bar just know
you're eating it I would be happy to
keep out goods that we know are made
under slave labor that's a very very
tiny I tell your wife say again I'm just
saying if I told my wife didn't she
couldn't have shocked I'd be tough oh no
no no slave labor okay John said but
yeah the the the I actually have a is
one of the curses of being an academic I
have a research assistant working on
this very issue now looking at the
extent of slave labor in the world and
and the findings are preliminary and the
student is from China he speaks Chinese
that's a good advantage and what what he
is discovering is that the the claims of
slave labor abroad are vastly overblown
much of what's called slave labor in the
first world such as the u.s. his labor
that's paid wages that are a lot lower
than we're paid naturally because these
are countries that are a lot poorer
workers who work in conditions that are
worse than the conditions under which
our workers work it's easy to label
something slave labor
in fact the world has very very little
if any of the kind of chattel slavery
that people think of when you hear the
term slave labor bandied about I'll take
the US Department of Labor's opinion
over his research assistants okay we are
going to have questions from those that
are doing live streaming think about
your questions from the audience you may
want to line up before that happens I
want to use moderators prerogative to
ask a couple of questions Rick do you
believe given the fact that chocolate
bars have a slave labor embodied in them
the chocolate bars should be completely
banned by the federal government no I do
believe though let me tell you I'll
answer because I was the public affairs
head of public affairs chief of staff
public affairs department of labor I'm
in the Bush administration george w bush
and i was responsible for i lab which
oversees child and slave labor around
the world doesn't oversee it reports on
it and the sometimes it was wander ten
years ago ten years ago in the book the
ivory coast was listed because of the
chocolate cocoa trade the manufacturers
the candy companies came together and
formed a coalition that was supposed to
be dealing with it ten this past year I
was fortunate enough to be there in the
Labor Department transition team for
president Trump I met with those same
people I used to work with ten years ago
and I asked them I looked it up I said
well what's happened in the last ten
years and the answer was nothing so our
should we should we be willing to say
and our customers point when something
comes in from customs that we know has
been produced with slave labor that
we're going to do something about it I
think we have a moral imperative to do
that what we ended we ended when the
Civil War ended slavery was ended in
America made a choice we can't go back
to eighteen six but you're against
banning chocolate bars though despite
that do I understand you correctly
my wife's against banning chocolate
Merson but I didn't ask your wife I'm
asking you
that's panning chocolate bars I think we
ought to create a five-year plan for for
them to become get into compliance and
then we should say no more okay
you do whatever your wife tells you and
I respect that done Johnny she's
watching I have to be careful Don you're
against banning chocolate bars look if
there's hard evidence that there are
slaves used to make chocolate bars I'm
willing to make an exception in that
case I I I doubt that you would actually
find that okay all right fair enough
and Rick my question to you is you said
that the wording should unilaterally
abolish all Townsend duties is clearly a
political imperative in your view and
therefore you reject it you said that it
should read ought to if indeed the
wording hypothetically if according read
it ought to unilaterally abolish all
towers and duties on imports and all
subsidies that's what ought to would you
then be in favor of the resolution no
because of two reasons number one the
affirmative also states that it should
be done unilaterally not with
reciprocity which i think is a recipe
for disaster secondly since the assumes
that there by on it says that there is a
that we would have no more need for our
trade agreements that's patently false
and that they would be unnecessary so
based on that's why I set of three
standards one being unilateral one being
should and one being you're being
unnecessary and it fails still would
fail on the other two standards I see
any comment about Rick's response Don do
you want I don't understand why you
would need a trade agreement if the
United States simply said we're going to
abolish all tariffs and import
restrictions period because other
countries want to have trade agreements
so they can let my to export your stuff
to them let them may have rules
let them have agreements as much as they
want yeah that's complain okay uh and
now we I think we have a question from
live streaming Jim Epstein is in the
audience and he's coming to the stage to
give us the questions on live streaming
Jim do you want to read and related to
questions from the audience at home
which
posted in the comments one is from Ellen
sandals this is for Don
how could removing all taxes and
regulations in the USA work in your
scenario when countries we trade with
continue to impose tariffs and
restrictions on us well we'd make
ourselves richer we would not restrict
our economic activity as much as other
countries for their economic activity
that goes on now I don't see why we
should say we're going to keep slashing
our own tires we're gonna keep slashing
our own face we're gonna keep cutting
off our own nose because other countries
are doing the same thing and we won't
stop doing it until they do it the world
would be a better place if everybody got
rid of taxes I would reduce them to you
know reasonable levels and reduce
regulations to reasonable levels we do
not have to wait though for other
countries to do the same thing in order
for us to do it and make ourselves
better a question for a rep now John
okay the second question is for both of
you it's from Steve McClean with respect
to the UK's exit from the European Union
a segment of leave proponents argue that
Britain should opt for no trade deal
with the EU in preference of global
bilateral trade deals well he'd be
interested in the debate participants
responses uh the question yeah okay Rick
take it away
well I think that each country has to
make their own decisions regarding what
how they want to behave in the world if
it were me I would if I were part of the
Great British government I would look
first across the pond at the United
States to be the first prick trade
partner and get as good a great deal
with the United States and then I'd look
across the channel at Europe and get a
getting deal with Europe because
ultimately I they're an island nation
they are trading is what they are and so
it'd be absurd for them to try to be a
kind of just an island without any trade
because they would be economically their
economy would collapse
so yeah they have to do trade deals I
think they should do one with us first
and
the you but they can walk and chew gum
and do both at the same time Don you do
you have response
I don't see why Britain couldn't just
say we're returning to the regime we had
in the mid 19th century no tariffs we
don't need trade deals with anyone we
just do not restrict imports into our
countries period it's easy and it makes
the country richer thank you all right
first question of the audience please
phrase your question as a question and
so take it away the gentleman it was in
front of the mic there yes is the
microphone there please yes thank you
both of you for a spirited debate the
question is related to monetary policy
so there's many ways to influence
international trade you know staking a
tariff or a duty as congressionally pass
is one way in other ways through
monetary policy I'd like to hear both
both of the the invitees discuss what
would be how would you would you agree
with the standard argument that a weaker
domestic currency favors exports a
stronger domestic currency favors
importers and if you had to choose what
would be your ideal monetary policy all
right thanks for the question do you
want to comment John yeah this is often
claimed that when a country
D values its currency that somehow makes
that country richer I think that's
nonsense
it might make exports from that country
temporarily less costly to foreigners
but when you devalue your currency which
that means is you're increasing the
supply of your currency relative to that
of other countries and so inflation
winds up running through the system and
so the price level adjusts over the long
run it is impossible for a country to
improve its export market by keeping its
currency too low because keeping its
currency too low means inflation much of
what is called in the modern world today
or much as what much of what is alleged
to be currency devaluation or currency
undervaluation in fact no such no such
thing china was accused of that a number
of years ago and in fact China was
really just pegging the yuan to the
value of the dollar it wasn't pernicious
in my view at all it was quite a
sensible and prudent move in
part Thank You Jon do you want to
comment mark sure yeah I'd love to talk
about currency manipulation and how it's
is destroying America but you know it's
a what we have is the Mont of the Fed no
longer controls our monetary policy our
monetary policy is controlled by those
who buy our Treasury bonds who buys our
by our debt and the people who buy our
debt and at least a trillion dollars
worth or the Chinese and so you've got a
so and what they do is when they when
they want to lower make our dollars
stronger they buy more debt and as a
result in when they when they want to
float it they they buy less I'm gonna
use a a well-known popular kind of pop
index it's the Big Mac index China has
over the past since they started doing
it a Big Mac in the United States costs
forty five percent more than the same
Big Mac in China it's a and in China
China in fact has a greater disparity as
a relatively developed economy in places
like Pakistan so yeah currency
manipulation is occurring and currency
manipulation is occurring by people who
want to you engage in predatory prices
predatory attacks on our country our
country our dollars artificially
stronger than it should be we are
exporting our inflation but eventually
running six hundred billion seven
hundred billion dollars for the deficits
every year is gonna come back and it's
gonna bite us
and when those customers no longer want
to buy the dollar but they want to dump
it yeah I should mention that the bit
the Big Mac measure was originated by
The Economist it is kind of interesting
I would imagine it's cheaper Chinese
labor that makes the Big Mac cheaper in
China by Cleveland but you're saying
slave labor but in Big Mac is a lot
cheaper there and I'm not surprised next
question the trips agreement is part of
part of GATT that protects intellectual
property and and and to use an example
within the pharmaceutical industry what
it implies is that countries around the
role except for the United States have
price control
and pharmaceuticals the United States
generally does not in some cases does
but generally does not it prohibits rien
portation but allows these other
countries to keep their price controls
so if we were to unilaterally lift those
that realtor tation with which which
represents restriction then the
countries could keep their price
controls they would still mandate that
pharmaceutical companies had to had to
sell at whatever their price control
price level was and then they would of
course export to the United States so
the question is how how could innovation
be preserved if there were simply a
flood of product at the whatever the
Thailand rate which is something like
ninety nine percent discount to what
what a product is sold for in the United
States they always said the threat of
those simply break the patent in certain
manufacturing and on their own and and
so the question is how can
pharmaceutical innovation be preserved
why would from Zucco company ever create
a new product ever again if they could
not sell it at what is required to
recoup their investment and innovation
take a question Don yeah look I'm not an
expert in intellectual property I'm not
even sure I agree with intellectual
property but that's not an that's not up
for debate
here and I'm willing to concede that at
the extent that we have intellectual
property protections agreements between
countries to maintain those protections
might be appropriate but look let's look
at the the the the core of the issue
here the arguments against free trade
have very little to do with intellectual
property they have very little to do
with slavery have very little do with
product quality they're all about jobs
are all about the alleged effective
foreign imports on domestic wages
they're all about the the fear tactics
stirred up about the trade deficit
they're not about intellectual property
they're about protecting American
producers from foreign competition
period and that that's pretty much all
of Trump's rhetoric
that's pretty much all of Bernie Sanders
rhetoric it's something actually when
Trump and Bernie Sanders pretty much
agree completely on trade issues right
and and so that's what I want to focus
on my my argument is that all these
subsidiary issues decide how to handle
intellectual property disputes how to
handle confirmed cases where we have
actual foreigners confirmed to be slaves
I agree that can be set aside that can
be handled separately but the overall
case from unilateral free trade is
pretty strong the US government does not
prevent you as a US citizen from
spending your money as you choose
regardless of whether you choose to buy
a domestically made product or a
competing product made abroad period
Rick
sure I'll answer the intellectual
property problem conundrum the free
trade argument is predicated on a basic
assumption that we all have the same
underlying values that we all have the
same value that property is treated the
same private ownership of property is
treated the same in the people where
we're trading it and where we're our
partners as it is in America that's not
true
China does not have the same view of
property as the United States try it
right now we have technology transfer
who transfer requirements being put on
US companies if they want to enter
Chinese the Chinese markets I would tell
them not to do it but that's what
they're doing in China is they're
grabbing
technology and grabbing intellectual
property protecting intellectual
property is fundamental to freedom
because if we don't control or the
product of our own minds what's the rest
of this about I mean what's the rest of
this about so professor Boudreau is
willing to throw that by the wayside
because he doesn't believe we need
reciprocal trade agreements that protect
private property he doesn't believe you
I didn't say you said we could do
without them we'll figure out some other
way so here's what you've got you've got
intellectual property is that the core
of freedom and fruit be through for
reciprocal trade agreements it's the
only way we can use the economic might
of the United States to enforce to
enforce protection of intellectual
property from our companies where it's
being stolen by people overseas we all
know what's happening we read about the
newspaper all time and that's why you
have to negate this proposition john
Mikami then Rick McCubbin did you want a
quick correction did Johnny briefly yeah
first of all I did concede that there
may be cause and and room for separate
agreements to deal with intellectual
property protections but I have a deeper
point right in a world of complete free
trade which is the world and I would
like to see or just unilateral u.s. free
trade if not complete world free trade
it's up to each company to choose
whether or not to sell its products in
foreign in foreign countries if if
Canada is allowing if Canada is keeping
the price of some US pharmaceuticals so
there are sold there artificially low
it's up to Merck and other US
pharmaceuticals to choose to deal in
that country not if they can't if they
choose to continue to sell there that's
their business they know the
consequences if not it's not up to the
government to restrict our freedom in
order to protect their profits and and
just to talk on the pharmaceutical
specifically and the question that was
asked if a country like Thailand or
India is stealing the intellectual
property producing the core product and
pennies on the dollar and then flooding
our markets because we don't have any
protections on it flooding our markets
with that product driving work out of
business because they spent billions of
dollars to develop that property and
your policy would allow it to be stolen
and sold the United States their
consumer so they can save a few pennies
on the product then you will have no
innovation in this country and you will
this destroyed the foundational
foundational element that is the
American greatness which is that we
build stuff we create stuff that's what
we do and when you're limiting our
intellectual property when you degrade
it down to a level of being just another
thing you are denying the very essence
of what America is and I reject that
wholeheartedly I don't realize we were
debating intellectual property here well
it's part of the free trade agreements
but
can be done independently of fridge it
can be done without a trade element to
it how I confess I haven't thought
through the details of how that would be
done but I don't see why
look Britain had unilateral free trade
from the mid 19th century until the the
20th century I don't think Britain
suffered because of any robbery of its
intellectual property Britain that was a
period of high growth so you believe
that 1850s is the same as the 25 2017 in
terms of the movement of property the
movement of people movement of ideas you
know the Internet's intervened between
them yes I'm aware that I'm aware that
this is not the 19th century but I don't
see any essential difference I don't see
why we've worked in the 19th century in
terms of the principles of freedom will
not work today next question would you
guys support economic sanctions against
apartheid South Africa support economic
sanctions against apartheid South Africa
was the question done you want to
respond it's a good question
you know if economic sanctions and
embargoes do in fact harm other
countries then it's curious that we use
the same policies to make ourselves rich
mrs. with Trump wants to basically use
economic sanctions against American
consumers right and put embargoes on on
on foreign goods coming into America
because he argues he and his fans
already that will make us make us rich
look yeah I know it's a it's a
hypothetical I'd have to see I don't
have a good answer to that okay good
answer I'll just tell you a little story
in 1978 I was a junior at the University
of Southern California and I had
politics sub-sahara Africa being taught
by a person who fought for the ANC which
was really kind of fun and I had an A in
the class until I answered that question
and the the question the answer was no
and here's why it seemed to me at the
time and I think the logic still room
that at the time we were opening up the
economic doors to the Soviet Union we're
opening up the economic doors to China
and it said my logic was this if we're
going to open up economic doors to those
who have nuclear weapons aimed at us
then we shouldn't shut economic doors to
people to countries that on a
geopolitical level support us and so my
answer at the time was no and because
I'm a man who tries to be consistent
throughout his life I retained that
position thank you next question yeah my
question is for mr. Boudreau about jobs
actually
so first philosophically speaking you
your argument seems to be that subsidy
trade restrictions sort of subsidize
less than optimally efficient production
in that if a steel worker should be laid
off for competing Chinese steel they can
then go and do a more more productive
job economically speaking but that
doesn't take into account at all the
productive capacity of the individual
person not everybody has equally equal
potential to be productive in different
roles you know some people might not
just be suited for the higher end more
sophisticated jobs and then you know
from a real-world example when you look
at places like Detroit and the Rust Belt
that have lost tremendous exporting and
manufacturing jobs and in the wake
people haven't gained new higher skilled
jobs in fact poverty of skyrocketed drug
uses skyrocketed and communities have
deteriorated and you might attribute
that to a variety of real-world factors
but the fact remains that it's not
upward mobility in the job market
doesn't seem to be as easy as the
philosophical philosophical step you
seem to make it two points number one
it's the the stagnation of the American
middle class is as much talked about
it's actually mythical if you look at
the data and you adjust the data
correctly and people have done this
including myself you see that there is
in fact no stagnation of the American
middle class middle class America today
is wealthier than it has ever been no
matter how you measure it right now of
course it is the second point there are
some people
who lose jobs and it's it's it because
of trade and that is difficult for them
the trouble though with restricting
international trade on that account is
that then if that's your concern
restricting international trade doesn't
go far enough
so take the steel worker that you just
mentioned suppose I'm an American
suppose I invent a new plastic that's a
perfect that's a really good substitute
for steel that new plastic puts the
steel worker out of a job do you think
the government should be in the business
of preventing me from inventing new
plastic mr. Manning doesn't think so
because that's a new innovation
intellectual property should Americans
be prevented from buying my new plastic
because buying my new plastic might put
that steel worker out of a job again
every month in the United States today
on average about 1.7 million jobs or
destroyed each mine again I'm not
talking about quits and again the total
the upper estimate of the number of jobs
that we've lost from trade with China
which has become a large trading partner
famously over the past 16 years is four
million jobs the fact is the number of
jobs that get destroyed in the economy
on a daily basis is huge and only a
small fraction of those have anything to
do with international trade and so if
you're going to protect people's jump if
you've got to protect people from losing
their jobs because you don't like
economic change you got to do far more
than stop international trade you have
to stop all economic you have to freeze
the economy where we have it now and and
that would be a calamity Rick nine point
five million people who ages 16 to 64
are not in the labor force today who
were in the labor force when China got
PNTR okay if you take the same labor
participation rate for those that age
group that's what we would have in if we
had that same labor participation right
we're seeing a hollowing out of America
we're seeing people giving up hope
that's why Trump won because people
looked around so the government hasn't
been for me I need a government who's
going to be on my side and not on the
Chinese
professor Boudreaux comes up with a four
million number I can't validate it or
not I can say this that every single day
the Chinese government wakes up and says
how do we win economically from the
United States and they're doing
everything they can to do that and the
United States government needs to start
thinking about the American people first
and foremost as well
Ricky write about the nine point five
million and just to put a fine point on
your insight that I put five million not
in the labor force and then you say then
we started trading with China
so you attribute the 9.5 million
dropouts to China trade well yeah
because here's what we know is true in
year 2000 we had a four point four
percent GDP we haven't had a four
percent GDP since then in the last ten
years we haven't been above three
percent GDP in fact in the last ten
years it's wrote this is hard to imagine
we've had less GDP growth in the last
ten years that at any time in recorded
history including the Great Depression
that's just a fact
that fact the China trade I attributed
directly to China trade the 2000 is the
launch point for the for the decline in
the manufacturing sector it's a launch
point for a variety of different factors
but the one thing we know is that we
have found ourselves since 2000 in a in
a world of hurt economically in the
United States and I will not accept the
new normal of lowering expectations I
believe we can do better and we should I
agree with that by the way Rick so I
want to weigh in that way John you're
one who so yes can I ask I like it can
ask a third question to mr. Manning I
guess he was a quiz for you at what
point in US history was US manufacturing
output at its peak adjusted for
inflation I'll let you tell me you're
the economics professor today we only
have six point seven percent are
actually our manufacturing has been cut
in half
the manufacturing sector doesn't have a
no percentage of the economy
as a percentage of the economy that is
true no oh it's a percentage of the
economy no no I'm oh no and we have and
we have nine and a half million people
who would who if the labor participation
rate had
in the same as it was in 2000 would be
in the workforce now they're not that's
bad they're not paying taxes they're
saying they're there on various health
public assistance programs and they are
it is a huge problem in this country
unless we fix it it's a seminal event
that happened in 2000 nothing to do with
Obama's policies nothing to do with
George Bush's in increase in the role of
government if we have it's all China
well it is a seminal event that did
happen in 2000 we also saw various other
nations how to see their percentage of
growths go down during that same time
frame but our bottom line is whether you
can attribute a small percentage of it
to China or a large percentage of China
but you can tactically deny the fact
that we have exported our manufacturing
sector overseas no our manufacturing
manufacturing more now than ever and in
fact if you look at if he's another
question when did the United States
become chiefly a service sector if you
divide it into services manufacturing
and agriculture the year is 1911 and if
you look at the trend of output in these
sectors over time services keep going up
as people get richer they want more
services we don't want more more and
more food and more and more things we
want more and more experiences as
countries get wealthier they they
consume more services we're consuming
more healthcare we're consuming more
more hospitality and leisure we're
consuming more education more of this
manufacturing output in the United
States is at its all-time peak
manufacturing employment peaked in 1979
that's because innovation which I
applaud innovation has dramatically
reduced the need for workers in the
manufacturing sector it's not China
people have estimated we've been many
studies have estimated the effect of
China on trade with China on innovation
and none of them find that China is a
major cause take mr. Manning's 9.5
million so I use 4 million let's go with
9.5 million basically doubling it so it
takes roughly five months five months of
regular job churn to cause to destroy
the number
of of jobs that the number of jobs have
each month is about 1.7 million that are
destroyed so that's roughly five or six
months we've been trading with China
since well before 2000 but they did
enter in 2000 at the WTO in 2001 so we
can use that as a mark date so it's it's
it's no matter how you look at the date
it's impossible to blame China for the
the numbers that you you you know it's
great really really if I I heard of more
specious argument okay what's specious
about I'm about to tell you explain to
tell you the speciousness we have a we
have a it's really interesting what the
churn rate is when you're the one who's
getting churned it's really not very fun
and when you have 9.5 million americans
being churned and your churn rate that
is a disaster for the country we have
seen that disaster taking place we're
seeing parts of it through the method
from the epidemic regulating heroin
we're seeing it manifests itself in so
many different ways if we don't get
people jobs and opportunity our country
will fail in other words professor
Boutros spoken like a tenured professor
so what looks like we don't have any we
don't have any further time for
questions I'm sorry
we're run out of time thank you to the
debaters and we thank you to any
questions these guys are gonna stick
around over wine as you can buttonhole
them that's what we do at the Philip or
forum we have probably better
discussions over wine at the bar later
on but we now have to conclude the
debate Don Boudreau you're gonna get
five minutes take the podium for your
final rebuttal
we see at the end here the real concern
Ric got very emotional about people
losing jobs I get very emotional of
people losing jobs too by the way it's
an ad hominem argument to criticize my
argument because I'm a tenured professor
I started favoring free trade when I was
18 long before I was tenured just by the
way but if you want to judge an argument
by the nature of the person who delivers
it then because you discount my arguing
because indeed I'm a tenured professor I
didn't make the rules I would get rid of
tenure I think it's a terrible system
but in order to be a college professor
in the United States today you have to
have tenure if you want to stick at to
get the job anyway the the argument here
at the end was that losing jobs is bad
trade with China causes some people to
lose jobs nine point five million is the
estimate we hear which is roughly the
number of jobs that are destroyed in
about five months because that's so
horrible we should stop or we should
restrict trade with China notice nothing
to do with intellectual property nothing
to do with with slavery it's just people
are losing jobs well again people lose
jobs anytime there's economic change
people lost jobs when the polio vaccine
was invented think of all those poor
people who lost jobs who made
wheelchairs and crutches and iron lung
machines people lose jobs when the IT
sector emerged highly innovative people
in secretarial pools people making
typewriters they too lost jobs as
agriculture became far more mechanized
starting in the 19th century lots of
people lost jobs in the agricultural
sector as manufacturing is becoming more
meta its innovation is replacing human
labor with machines people are losing
jobs in the manufacturing the number of
jobs in manufacturing sector declines
this is the nature of economic growth
this is called creative destruction and
it is creative yes people lose jobs
there are jobs destroyed but if you are
going to based economic policy on the
wish on the desire to prevent people
from losing jobs
because some foreigner sells you
something then again you can't stop
there you have to stop consumers from
changing the way they spend their money
for any reason there's what why should
we why should we feel worse for the
worker who loses a job to a Chinese
import then we feel for a worker who
loses a job because Steve Jobs built a
machine that now has an app that makes
that job redundant both people whose
jobs they both suffer they're both part
of this job churn there's nothing unique
about international trade in in reducing
jobs the problem is people like to
demonize far it's easier to demonize
farms it's difficult to demonize fellow
fellow consumers so I that's all I have
to say okay Rick five minutes for
rebuttal
take it away Rick thank you I'm gonna
since you guys are gonna be voting let
me remind you you know I'm in politics
okay I gotta remind you what you're
voting about the US government should
unilaterally abolish all tariffs and
duties on imports and all subsidies to
exports thereby making all reciprocal
trade agreements with other countries
unnecessary once again if the resolution
failed on its the unilateral level and
you believe reciprocity is a right idea
then you need to vote negate the
proposition to if you don't believe it
fits of real-world description which
professor Boudreaux kind of admitted
then you have to negate the proposition
and three if you believe that the trade
you trade agreements become unnecessary
and/or do not become unnecessary and
other things matter like intellectual
property they're incorporating them that
we get because of our economic might to
force other countries to sub to accept
intellectual property then you have to
negate I'm gonna close by allowing
professor Boudreaux to close for me from
his book
Paige is 135 36 you get a lot of rocks
and harbors from this fellow I apologize
political reality be what it is
government's very seldom practice
unilateral free trading perversely a
government will remove rocks from its
harbors only when it can be sure that
other governments will remove rocks from
theirs and if are the government's loot
toss more rocks into the harbors each
government temptation is to throw more
toss more rocks into its own but after
the catastrophic orgy of choking harbors
with rocks between the wars government
officials realize that they had to find
some means of mutually agreeing to clear
their harbors that is to lower tariffs
and open trade cat and now at WTO the
World Bank and the IMF are the principal
monuments is admirable realization GAD
especially is responsible for the
extraordinary post-world War two
reduction in harbor clogging tariff
rates now get this for free trade /
purists GATT and WTO are often
annoyingly modest and slow and moving
the world towards freer trade the
results though cannot be seriously
disputed trade today is much more free
than it was just fifty years ago and
there is no sign at today of any major
retreat on this front without GAD in WTO
this progress is highly unlikely to
occur okay this is the end of his book
this is how this is a book that he has
science to his students he makes them
pay sixty one bucks to get it it's too
is I had to pay it so you know I'm a
little miffed too it was written in 2008
love and update so they can't use the
old books but it's a but it argues it
makes the case I choose to go with
Professor Boudreau who teaches his
students one thing rather than Don
Boudreau who tells you something else
you must vote to negate thank you Rick
like that could that concludes the
debate now the judge and jury are you in
the audience have got to vote on the
resolution for against or undecided and
the thousands of people who have been
watching us on streaming in Fairfax
Virginia where Don comes from and by the
way we're Rick works there both sons of
Fairfax Virginia that entire town is
voting even as we speak on the
resolution for against or undecided and
while you're considering your vote after
these two very spirited debaters have
stirred your mind and turns it up so
down about these issues and then turned
it right again vote your conscience vote
honestly on how you feel and while
you're considering your vote and while
the people in Fairfax are considering
their vote I want to again announce that
next month we're going to have a great
debate on welfare in this country in
January a great debate involving me
directly on selfishness being a virtue
and I also want to thank my wife Masako
Kobayashi who is now behind the
sumptuous tables of food that she
prepared and that you've already availed
yourself of there's a cash bar that
where you can buy drinks alcoholic and
non-alcoholic I want to thank our great
unsung hero my friend John Quincy who
handles just about everything else for
us the Smith Family Foundation Don Smith
who pays virtually all our bills much
appreciated and Kate should we close the
voting know the people in Fairfax are
still thinking about it
and we want what's it keep it open for
the link precincts absolutely and should
shut down Smith returned that 61 bucks
for that book to every one of his
students
should is part of what your students are
deciding on time and what I'm sorry no
this time yeah okay
and while you're considering how to
debate
I want to thank Rudolf Houser who's our
bouncer in front who who's the guy who
tells us whether you have one minute or
five minutes remaining
I want to thank our our terrific
stand-up comedian for warming us all up
with some of those off-color jokes of
his we're gonna have some great stand-up
comedians in the future libertarian
community comedians all who can make fun
of libertarians as those comedians
invariably do and furthermore Kate helps
house the voting have we heard for the
from the back precincts and from the
people in Fairfax well okay well that
variably happens okay yeah because yeah
yeah okay well we'll give them about a
five four three two one to vote anybody
in the audience who has not voted please
do so and the precincts at who have been
live streaming please have them vote and
we're gonna be reporting the results in
percentages so you're gonna be pulling
the vote up and so one five four three
two one you're closing the voting
reporting is closed and please bring me
the results okay
yeah okay all right well this is
interesting
the yes votes in favor of don went from
a little under 39% to a little over 57%
so Don picked up nearly 19 points the no
votes in favor of Rick went from a
little over 25 points to a little over
33 points so Rick pin picked up eight
points Don picked up 19 percentage
points picked up eight points they both
did well
however the Tootsie Roll does go to Don
Boudreaux
you